hey stop what's up steven how's it going
just looking at
pictures of babies i just got this
amazing opportunity to go on a worth of
episode
and do cheap first expensive dates cool
yeah but uh my girlfriend is right now
in ohio
so she can't do it so you want me and
tyler to do it yes i would love that
only for you stephen yes okay
pack my bag are we going to vegas no no
no we're not going to vegas
no vegas today we're going to try out
three different dates at three
drastically different price points
and we're gonna see which one is the
most worth it at this price
unfortunately my girlfriend
is currently in ohio okay uh r.i.p she's
not
dead so i thought who better to bring on
these dates than
my favorite couple of buzzfeed thank you
wait so you're not coming with us yeah
we want you to be there
i'll film it i think it sounds great
because we're going all the way to vegas
so you know we're not going to vegas
going to vegas
baby not doing that just say it's vegas
vegas that's it
all right we're here at doc wyler beach
i brought my friend stop and tyler
to enjoy the beautiful day i packed them
a nice lunch
the coolest thing about the beach you
can do so many different things
literally the
world is your oyster haha on the beach
yay
it's so nice out here it is amazing we
got to set up our blanket babe
ty let's see what stephen packed us yeah
for lunch
i love you
i love the beach i've always been into
the beach we're kind of like water peeps
not only do i love the beach but it's a
beautiful day that's so cathartic like
the smell just relax the wind well
obviously like living in l.a
you're never too far from the beach so
it's always like kind of an easy option
getting to the beach maybe it's like gas
cost that's about it
there's like this great uh dynamic where
like there's gonna be like restaurants
and ice cream and places we could get
something to drink
close by right tyler's a cheap date
what's happening
how about that beach though it was
fantastic and what was your favorite
part of that well i took a nice little
nap yeah
it was uh really relaxing i feel like
the inner
child inside of me comes out at the
beach day facts did you know
that date palms can take up to four to
eight years before bearing through so
it's a long incubation period yeah
it's like dating somebody in real life
it takes 48 years to have babies you
said it not me
well i don't it actually takes a lot
less time than that this date is a
middle price date would you say it's
more of a wooing date more of a get to
know you date we're going to go to a
painting class sophia has never gone
painting with me so actually this is a
perfect activity for us to try together
we're already you know two years in so
it's not like oh wow
bad a painting deal breaker
i'm ann bridges and we're in my studio
today the class that we're doing today
is called introduction to acrylic
painting aprons
thank you it's been a while since i've
worn an apron i want to start by saying
the class is supposed to be fun
you can have a little bit of pressure if
you come to an art class about doing it
perfectly and the point is to be here
and just relax for two hours i start out
by just talking a little bit about how
color works in the light and in the
shadow
and then i put a still life up and just
show them step by step
on how to start how to get the color in
and how to finish this makes a really
unique day it's really light-hearted i
think sophia and tyler are going to do
great i'm not great at painting but
it's just really fun especially when
there's no expectations for perfection
now
what i'm worried about is trying to
achieve painting that just cause like
i know i can't oh yo you're gonna be so
[Music]
surprised
that's beautiful sophia that's perfect
my inner overachiever is like thank you
i'm hearing like these good compliments
for sofia i'm really excited to see what
she's done over there
you're doing great too all right well
i've actually consciously been holding
off and looking at sofia's until this
point so why don't we
turn each others over and show one two
three
wow yours is good yours is so cute
because mine looks like a five-year-old
did it no
it doesn't no the colors are good
actually
actually good painting baby good job
so i had lipstick on is it gross thank
you so much
this is so fun we had a great arts and
crafts vibe absolutely took me right
back into like uh
you know my school days and i love you
both did beautifully i thought it was
really fun i actually
really liked it yeah it was a very
innocent and sweet date and it made me
want to pinch your little cheeks
yeah i just hit your face i'm sorry
state facts 43
of singles have fallen in love with
somebody that they were not initially
attracted to yeah
that sounds familiar that sounds yeah
that sounds like right i mean i you know
i was always
that's not true i don't know for soppy
pops tyler and i were friends for a
while before we started dating
so i think that we grew into it and now
finally the most expensive
the most luxurious date tyler me and
soph are going to take you
on a romantic helicopter ride across los
angeles
what yeah what yeah helicopter ride this
is an
awesome way to close the day spoiler
alert i am afraid of heights okay so but
steven you can't leave us now
[Music]
my name is venita i'm the helicopter
pilot here and i'll be taking
tyler and sophia on a tour tonight i
think the coolest part about this date
is that it's something that we
never really get to do and we have
barely ever done or even thought of
doing
we roll them up and we bring them to the
hangar there is a cabana in here that
overlooks the airport
oh wow now this is like the rainforest
cafe
so you can see all the airplanes coming
in and out of here and they get a couple
of roses
champagne couple of french places so
it's a very intimate thing for 45
minutes to do before the tour so much
harder to eat that way then i
start walking them out to the helicopter
we take a couple pictures
in front of the helicopter i give them
the safety briefing i load them up and
then we're on our way to whatever
route that they chose for the night
what's great is that it's different
and you get to see the city in a
different perspective that most people
don't get to in their lifetime
i mean i think it'll be fun i think
there'll be some adrenaline i think
stephen might cry
yeah and i think that it's gonna be a
great time yeah this date was gonna be
that much better because steven's gonna
be up there with us
[Music]
great tour over van nuys over
calabasas over to panga canyon we saw
will smith's house
that was the highlight i mean will smith
besides being updated
but then we got to be like right over
sort of the ocean like right
outside of malibu and that was so cool
and this is places that we've been to
a lot we've driven up and down that
malibu pch right there
and like seeing from this angle was just
just it was incredible i like to imagine
a little bit like a jasmine and aladdin
like magic
carpet ride yeah okay but just with
steven and venita there as well
it was really fun to do because it's
more just like we get to look at stuff
and hang out
rather than trying to like schmooze that
said again
even if you were early on a date and you
held off sort of the romantic time until
afterwards it's a perfect date
absolutely great
[Music]
romance that's the definition of it
right there
guys we did it tripod went on three days
except it was
mostly for you guys a little bit it was
a tripod
so obviously all of these date options
were amazing but if you had to choose
one
which date did you feel like was the
most worth it i thought the helicopter
date was
so cool yeah i'm so glad we got to do it
but it just isn't something that i would
see us doing on the red
i like the painting date just because it
was a little bit out of something we
usually do we don't usually like plan
little activities i've got together
i think that the beach date was the best
really simple
it really let us be able to talk you
want to say thank you guys for catching
these days out for me we had a good time
if we need to call upon the third wheel
and be like hey like listen
we're trying to go to this place i don't
know vegas
third leg of the tripod yes confirmed
next episode
vegas baby confirmed